snowden is directed by Oliver Stone and
stars Joseph gordon-levitt as Edward
Snowden the man who leaked classified
documents to the press letting America
know that we were under surveillance
it's also the story of his relationship
with Lindsey Mills played by shailene
woodley as well as everything
surrounding his eventual decision to
leak those documents to the press when
it comes to any filmmaking but
especially Oliver Stone films I try to
check my personal beliefs at the door
because he's a filmmaker who's very much
so attracted to politically charged
material so that can be harder because a
lot of times his movies have messages he
really wants you to think the way he's
thinking but it's important with this
film and really all films to judge the
film on its merits of its filmmaking
it's writing it's acting it's directing
because really in 30 or 40 years if my
review of Snowden is being watched by
somebody are they gonna care about
today's modern times no they want to
know if the movies any good so I'm going
to talk about the movie Oliver Stone
does some very innovative things in this
film with the camera I really like the
way this film looked he shot it on a
very new camera the Alexa 65 this is a
beautiful looking movie very crisp very
clear and it does its best to make a lot
of technical jargon mainstream enough
for audiences to appreciate if you've
never seen the documentary citizen 4
which is the real-life doc about these
events in this film is going to be more
interesting to you it's a story that's
endlessly fascinating and it definitely
has a subject that is also fascinating
but if you've seen citizen 4 then some
of these events are gonna feel a little
more like old news to you this is
definitely a more mainstream attempt to
make this film more accessible to your
everyday audience member Joseph
gordon-levitt in this film is incredible
if you have seen that documentary this
is the vissa Jared Snowden he sounds
exactly like him he looks as close to
him as any Hollywood actor who's famous
he did a fantastic job in this movie
shailene woodley is also really good one
of the best performances I've seen from
her as Lindsey Mills she had a very
vulnerable real sense to her and this
relationship between these two people
really grounded the film in some form of
humanity because you need that for this
character you can't just have it be
about that integral moment where he
leaked these documents and made that
choice really all the performances are
amazing Nicholas
shows up in this movie and he was a very
entertaining presence technically this
is a very well directed movie with great
performances but I saw this movie
yesterday and I had to sleep on it
because something about it was bugging
me and I just couldn't pinpoint it and
actually took me awhile to come up with
what my problem with this movie was we
have at the core of this film a
protagonist that is endlessly
fascinating a story that is resonant and
imperative to our times but something
about the movie is just unremarkable
because a lot of it builds to one moment
we know is coming when he eventually
makes this decision everything else
surrounding that is a bit conventional
sometimes real-life stories no matter
how compelling they may be or how
important they may be just don't
translate to film very well and a lot of
that is due to the fact that Edward
Snowden appears in this film to be a
perfectly normal person who led a very
abnormal life and sometimes it's just
not theatrically very compelling but at
the same time it could have been a lot
more interesting if Oliver Stone had
trimmed this movie a little more
carefully it's a very long film and
sometimes the pacing drags as a result
because he seems to have this intrinsic
need to show you everything that you
need to know about this man and certain
details just don't really translate that
well to film because it's like okay I
get it he did that he did that he did
that he did that but what I really want
to know is what drove him to do this and
you do get those moments but
unfortunately the film as a whole just
wasn't very entertaining
I appreciate the film on its technical
merits and the fantastic performances
but as a whole overall film I could
never see myself free watching this
again and I don't think it's gonna have
that timeless appeal that films like JFK
platoon born on the fourth of July had
also the film makes a choice near the
end a very ballsy choice it's the kind
of choice beer like that better work if
you're gonna do that and it kind of does
like it reveals something and you're
like oh okay that's okay all right I
guess in the end if you're a huge Oliver
Stone fan you're going to appreciate
certain parts of this movie it's not one
of his best films it's not one of his
worst and unfortunately is not that
great return to form that I was hoping
it was going to be but it's still a
movie that is
relevant enough and interesting enough
for mainstream audiences that I think
people will at least find some enjoyment
in it I'm gonna give Snowden a b-minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to this Sunday
because I'm gonna be starting a new
review series leading up to rings I'm
gonna talk about some of the other ring
films including the first Japanese ring
as well as the two American the ring and
the ring two films this Sunday ring I'm
looking forward to reviewing that you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]